the maximum value of the expression 1
over sine squared of theta plus 3 sine
theta cosine theta plus 5 cosine squared
of theta is so let's let's rewrite this
so this is 1 over 1 over so i have a
sine squared of theta
i have a sine squared of theta
and then at least my brain whenever i
see a sine squared of theta i always
look for cosine squared theta of theta
because i know that when i take the sum
of them it equals one and i don't have
just one cosine squared theta here i
have five cosine squared theta so let me
just take one of them so i have a plus
cosine squared theta and since i took
one of them i only have four of these
left so plus 4 cosine squared theta and
then i have this stuff plus
3 sine
of theta cosine of theta so what this
first step allowed me to do is just turn
these two characters right over here
sine squared theta plus cosine squared
theta that is equal to one so we've
simplified it to one over
one over one
plus now let's think about how we can
write cosine squared of theta i'll write
our identities here
cosine squared of theta and we've proved
these in the trigono trigonometry
playlist this is equal to
1 plus cosine 1 plus cosine of 2 theta
all of that over 2. and my goal here is
i really just want to get everything
well i really just want to simplify it
and maybe we'll do calculus we'll use a
little calculus to find the minimum
value of the denominator which would
give us the maximum value of the
numerator
so let's see cosine squared of theta is
equal to this
so 4 times this is just going to be so 4
times this the 4 divided by 2 is 2 so
it's going to be 2 times this numerator
so it's going to be 2
plus 2 cosine
of 2 theta that's this term right here
and then this term
this term right over here we could use
the trig identity that
sine of two theta is equal to two sine
of theta
cosine of theta or you divide both sides
by two you get one half sine of two
theta is equal to sine of theta
cosine
of theta so this is this right over here
this part right over here is going to be
one half sine of two theta but we're
multiplying it by three so it's going to
be plus three halves
sine of two theta
sine of
two theta
and let's see this part over here
clearly simplifies
this is three so let me just rewrite it
this is one over
plus 2 cosine of 2 theta
plus 3 halves
sine
of 2 theta and we're really just looking
for the minimum we're looking for the
minimum value of the denominator which
would give us the same as the maximum
value of the numerator would just be one
over this minimum value so let's see how
how low we can get assuming we're above
zero let's see how low we can get for
this denominator right here we're just
going to look for its minimum value so
one thing we can do just to simplify
things the minimum value of this is
going to be the same the min
the min of this thing i don't want to
write it there because it kind of
confuses the problem the minimum value
of 3 plus 2 cosine
2 theta plus 3 halves sine
of 2 theta is going to be the same thing
as the minimum value of 3 plus i'm just
going to do the substitution that 2
theta is equal to x that just simplifies
things a little bit you don't have to do
that but just so 3 plus 2 cosine of x
plus 3 halves
sine
of x so this is a pretty simple
expression let's see how we can figure
out its minimum value and my temptation
is to take the derivative find out where
the derivative is equal to zero and then
that will either be a maximum or a
minimum point
so let's take the derivative the
derivative of this expression right over
here with respect to x well derivative
of three with respect to x is zero
derivative of two cosine of x is
negative
negative two sine of x
derivative of three halves sine of x is
going to be plus 3 halves cosine of x
and then that is going to be equal to 0.
we want to find where the slope is 0
because that's either going to be a
maximum or a minimum point and let's see
we can
add
we could add 2 sine of x to both sides
so we get 3 halves cosine of x is equal
to 2
sine of x and then we can divide both
sides both sides of this equation
by
let's divide by 2 first i want to skip
too many steps so 3 4 cosine of x is
equal to sine
of x and we can divide both sides by
cosine of x so we get 3
over 4 is equal to sine of x over cosine
of x
which is the same thing as the tangent
of x so an x value that gives us 3 or
the tangent of an x value gives us 3 4
is going to give us either a maximum or
a minimum point so let's think about
this let's think about this a little bit
let me draw my unit circle
so let's think about the two
the two x values that will give us a
tangent of three-fourths
so let me draw my unit circle
and that's a unit circle
let me draw a unit
this is always the hardest part so let
me draw this
all right there is my unit circle so how
can i get a triangle or or well yeah
let's think about it that way how can i
get a triangle who where an angle is a
tangent of three-fourths remember
tangent is opposite over adjacent
right tangent is opposite over adjacent
so
if this is my triangle right over here
if this is x
opposite over adjacent is equal to three
fourths so opposite could be three and
adjacent could be four and we hopefully
immediately recognize this this is a
this is a 3 4 5 triangle because it's a
right triangle 3 squared plus 4 squared
is 25 which is 5 squared so this is a 3
4 5 triangle now there's two tangent
values so x could be like this so this
obviously isn't this isn't a unit
hypotenuse over here but we can divide
everything by five and it would be so we
could have this situation
we could have this situation over here
where this is x if this is a unit circle
the hypotenuse is one this is three over
five and this is four over five this
would tangent of x here tangent of x
would give us three fourths but is this
going to give us a maximum value or
minimum value well over here both cosine
both cosine of x and sine of x are going
to be positive so both of these are
going to be positive values so it's
going to probably maximize
maximize this expression over here now
the other
x that gives us the same tangent
remember the tangent is really just the
slope of the radius in the unit circle
would be
the angle would be this angle this is
the same this has the same tangent value
so this x
this x over here
this x over here in this case the
tangent is still the tangent is still
going to be three-fourths but over here
the sine and cosine are negative so over
here
over here the x-coordinate or the cosine
is going to be negative four-fifths
and the sine value or or the y-values
here is going to be negative
three-fifths and this will give us
this will give us a minimum point
because here everything is every both
the sine and the cosine are negative so
let's use let's use this x right over
here and notice we don't even have to
figure out what the x is because we know
that if the tangent over here is
four-fifths this either both the the
sign is going to be the sine is going to
be three-fifths and the cosine is going
to be four-fifths or which will give us
a maximum point or the tangent could be
three-fourths and then the sine will be
negative three-fifths and the cosine
will be negative four fifths so let's
use these over here so the minimum is
going to be equal to three plus
when two times cosine of x we're using
this one over here so two times cosine
of x cosine of x here is negative four
fifths negative four-fifths and then
plus three-halves plus three-halves
times the sine of x sine of x here is
negative three-fifths
negative three-fifths and what is this
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to three
plus
this is negative eight fifths
three maybe i should write three minus
eight fifths
three minus eight fifths
minus nine tenths minus nine tenths and
so this is going to be equal to we could
put everything over ten thirty over ten
minus sixteen over ten right that's
eight fifths
minus nine over 10 and this gives us
what
this gives us 5 over 10
5 over 10 or one half
so the minimum value the minimum value
for our denominator everything we've
been dealing with so far has been our
denominator the minimum value of all of
this business over here the minimum
value is one-half
so the maximum value that this whole
expression takes is when the minimum
value is one-half so we get one over
half
which is equal to two and we're done